hello everyone I'm Alana oshawala and
welcome to my channel and today we are
talking about The Last of Us episode
five this is my like solar review I will
have a discussion up probably tomorrow
with Mike Flanagan and Kate Siegel
talking all about the episode and I'm
super excited to talk to those two
because they'll be the first two people
that I've had on this like discussion
podcast do you think I'm doing who
haven't played the game so very excited
um and obviously I'm late to this one
because it aired early and I'm trying
not to do any extra work on weekends at
the moment so I was like well it's gonna
have to go out Monday or Tuesday the
internet can wait um I'm always late
anyway so
episode five uh I think is one of the
most brutal episodes of Television that
I have ever seen this one was like a
hard to walk away from that kind of
thing where it's just like
leaves you
and and stays with you for a really long
time and I think a lot of that was down
to the performance
um it was very very powerful even if I
knew what was coming
just really tore my heart out and then
spat all over it and stomped on it and
and vomited on it and then I just sat
there staring at the TV like
damn it was very very heavy and I think
that's exactly what it should have been
they executed on that um absolutely
beautifully and that's my spoiler-free
Impressions but from now just get into
the spoilers so this is obviously part
two of what is basically one episode
four and five definitely gonna get a
very well sort of like a little feature
film or I guess a long feature film uh
but we learn all about Kansas City and
there was a lot of stuff that I found to
be very very interesting and some things
that I found to be lacking and that I
felt like this awk was one of the ones I
felt was a little bit weaker but that's
very easy to say when the rest of the
show is like so good that I would have
given numerous episodes of 10 out of 10
right like it being the weaker is pretty
common for the middle of a TV show
um
and I'm also not saying it's bad it's
just that everything is so good
take that with a grain of salt so we
very quickly meet Henry and Sam and
obviously the biggest change from the
game is that uh Sam is deaf which I felt
was handled really beautifully here
there is something very interesting
about a deaf character existing and
communicating in a post-apocalyptic
world and I love the use of the notepad
and the Curiosity of what he was going
to write and then of course it leaving
us with the last
shot of it saying I'm sorry how
incredibly heartbreaking I think it was
also really nice here to see Ellie be a
little bit more of a child uh with Sam
and to see Joel and Henry bargain with
each other and I feel like the
relationship and the parallels between
those two
you know long-term relationship story
about love what do you do in this world
with these um two groups of two people
was was really beautifully handled I
also appreciated that this episode
really ramped up the infected we saw
more of them where I think in the last
episode we didn't really see any at all
we just sort of saw the the sinkhole I
guess underneath a building which turns
out may have just been a sinkhole but
obviously was related to a bloater as a
lot of us expected which looked amazing
it looked so good oh my God jumping
ahead here but the girl who played the
like acrobat clicker was so creepy and I
love that they did that um I know that
actress is actually a gymnast and I feel
like that was just so haunting and I
really do love again the things that
this show is doing to kind of creep us
out where sometimes it's really
difficult to because we've seen a
million zombie shows that they have to
kind of handle things a little bit
differently to have a different effect
on us and so we're not just like ah
zombie infected whatever they are
escalating things to make them even
creepier and I loved that the infected
in this were very cool and the sniper
sequence is obviously basically one to
one the same as the game very very
similar with a similar amount of tension
a similar amount of fear even though
we're not the ones shooting this time
um we're watching somebody do it and I I
loved that whole segment that was the
stakes felt so high the swaps between
the two Vantage points and perspectives
great use of the format obviously um I
felt like that was genuinely thrilling
it was a great action sequence to end
what was otherwise
um a kind of very self-contained couple
of episodes I think this is also the
most infected we've seen moving on
screen I'm pretty sure and I think there
were some pieces where I spotted some CG
in the movements um but I mean I could
be wrong I'm not even totally confident
I think I did and I was like oh that
movement was a little bit strange but
for the most part just really
beautifully choreographed action high
stakes and a lot of very frantic Panic
that a lot of directors I think make
difficult to follow but we very clearly
knew what was going on here which means
I think they nailed it also obviously a
very consistent theme of um saving
children saving the future in this
episode and
and how the world is kind of losing
innocence uh is beated across this
episode in various ways in ways that I
felt like I'm glad the show tackled
that's a question everybody has to ask
is what does it mean for the future how
are we looking after the Next Generation
do they have a place in this world and I
guess the answer oftentimes is no and
yes again for the most part a more
self-contained episode with um actor
Lamar Johnson
playing Henry just beautifully he's such
a good mirror to Joel as well like a
good mirror of
who Joel is supposed to be for Ellie um
which he is obviously growing towards in
a way that I think is very well paced
and the two kids bonding because they
just have that shared childlike nature
it was very nice to see and something we
haven't seen for Ellie otherwise and
frankly probably won't see again
honestly it was even more of a bummer
because I was enjoying watching them all
so much like I wish that Henry and Sam
could have continued on the journey with
us
um but I guess I felt that way when I
was playing the game as well so it was
like it sucks to lose them and that's a
credit to the writing of course we also
got the underground tunnels here which I
was very excited to see
um that that were obviously very
different to how they are in the games
it was sort of a fake out because I was
so sure that we would have infected down
there
um and not having them there I guess is
like kind of a nice deviation instead
we've got like a very wholesome nice
classroom which I think again is a great
judge the theme of this episode being
childhood and in a sense they just
nailed it across the board it was also
really cool to actually see a bunch of
Easter eggs in that setting in the show
um including the comics of course
definitely one of the sad aside stories
in the game that we got to see a whole
bunch of reference to which is always
very fun all leading us towards the
ending which again I already touched on
at the start but the end of this episode
is just so heartbreaking
um so just like the performance from
Lamar is really what did this we have
the reveal that Sam has been bitten and
Ellie tries to save him and I'm not sure
if she thinks she can I think she
probably didn't think she could I think
she probably thought that it wouldn't
work
and was doing it to comfort him but I'm
not actually sure about that the process
of Sam attacking Ellie and then Henry
shooting him and and questioning what
he's done that scene was just so brutal
and heartbreaking and impactful I just
loved it I adored it it was incredible
it just so raw and real
um just just an incredible performance
there just 10 out of 10. that's all I
can say I wish I could find words to
articulate how positively I feel about
it but I don't even know how to do that
I loved about this episode and there are
certainly plenty of it um I still
obviously feel very positively about it
for the most part for what I didn't love
about this episode it was actually that
I felt like we didn't really get
the Insight on Kathleen that I sort of
assumed we would from the previous
episode I was like well this is clearly
like half of an awk or half of the story
it very much felt that way we're going
to find out why she's the leader and
how she overthrew fedra in theory why
all these people follow her so blindly
because they often say that they do and
she's clearly very evil she displays
that in in the scene in the bedroom
um but she doesn't have a conscience in
a way that a lot of other people do but
I didn't think that was really like
something that would stand out in this
kind of world so then the addition of
that character
um to me especially when combining these
two episodes just kind of felt a little
bit unnecessary love seeing the human
side of the conflict love seeing how a
city holds together outside of uh one of
the qzs
um definitely got a little bit of
insight on that but it wasn't as much as
I hoped it feels like it either should
have been a bit more we should have
gotten more information about how
Kathleen specifically came to power or
how they function as a community where
they get food from you know just the
little tidbits like that that build out
the world a little bit more or way less
that she should have been like a less
important bad guy we shouldn't have had
as many scenes where it's just Kathleen
talking to some somebody and showing her
desperation because I felt like again
just for me personally the payoff wasn't
really there and I was definitely
expecting it to be there um so I'd be
interested if anyone has a totally
different take care of maybe you think
there's something that I missed which is
totally possible but that that was uh
really the first like thing about this
entire show that I've been like oh
obviously the creators who know what
they're doing like I have no um doubt
that they know much better than I do so
really it's a preference but yeah I
guess I guess I felt just a little bit
like the Kathleen storyline was a little
bit lacking or too ever done it uh it
could have found a different balance
there I think but I can't really overall
say that this is a weaker episode
because I think it has like such a
fantastic ending and what it does for
the four characters who are really the
focus is incredible that action at the
end was fantastic
um the little bits and pieces we did see
was super satisfying just that one
little Arc beat through these last two
episodes I didn't really feel like paid
off for me a whole lot and maybe there
is still more to come uh maybe we will
find out a little bit more about her I
just kind of doubt it what I will say
about every scene with Kathleen
um which like even though it's a
deviation or like a b story to the main
plot is that it still felt very tense
the tension is at 100 the whole way
through they never lose that
which is an absolute Testament but yeah
I feel like there's never a single
moment throughout this whole thing where
I've been even close to thinking about
anything else you know how sometimes you
can watch something and your mind will
just be like oh I need to do the dishes
or whatever not once when I'm watching
this show for every single episode I am
so enamored with it and I don't want to
watch anything else and I am loving it
so those are my quick thoughts on
episode five I will have a podcasty chat
up tomorrow we're not going to do it
live
um it'll just be up on YouTube not on
Twitch with Mike Flanagan and Kate
Siegel all about episode five as well
I'm super excited to hear their
perspective and throughout this week
when I can have time just a lot going on
right now I will continue streaming the
game on Twitch leading up to next Sunday
where we get episode six we are over
halfway
I can't wait to see how the rest of the
world reacts to the ending
I'm excited